So, ten years from now,
I think it's going to be very important
for people to really have
an intimate sense and knowledge of technology
and where technology is going
because it drives every profession today,
and not just using a computer,
but really understanding at the core
what makes it work.
But beyond that, I also think
that it's going to be really important
for people to have sort of a global mindset
because we're now in a world
where our economy is a global economy.
We're all interconnected,
and, you know, you're going to be working with people
from all walks of life,
from all over the world.
And I think it's very helpful to understand other cultures,
and if possible, other languages.
I think it would be a centerpiece
of whatever it is that you're doing.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.